[Musique]
monsieur là c'est vrai ce qu'ont dû
sûrement ouangani personne vous êtes le
meilleur des gardes du corps
vous pouvez tirer si bâle au même
endroit
[Musique]
beauport
mon père était scientifique il a créé un
sérum d'amour rendant irrésistible celui
qu'il utilise ce parfum est inodore
coach est celui qui le respire compte
une explosion de l'attirance émotionnel
c'est n'importe quoi ce parfois mais
j'annonce un si ça marche je change de
sexe pour un plus grand
comment
il reste combien de temps pour retrouver
la mallette 47 eur qu'est ce que vous
foutez là vous gênez venu vous ai dit
gales
[Musique]
et c'est non
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
moi il m'a dit que tu avais des ménages
et à wattrelos courneuve parce que tu as
eu des problèmes avec les encore vous
donner à l'administration fiscale
un million sept cent cinquante mille
euros parce que moi faut que les congés
payés
[Musique]
on déménage moi je suis au bout du monde
la courneuve une incivilité toutes les
minutes c'est pas une ferme bio si vous
êtes notre chef d'état déchu mais non
mais si je vous présente samica la
gentillesse de faire visiter la cour
pardon je connais je te reconnais tous
ces germes avoir besoin
fred m'a demandé de vous donner quelques
conseils sur le quartier s'il vous plaît
aux affaires ce sont là je vois et pour
le recrutement de l'avoir au moins
quatre nouvelles recrues dans la zone
franche break even monde là non pas pour
une bagarre pour du travail
mais selon son associé la décharge
n'avait péta dès que tu rue alors qu'il
n'avait rien fait moi je sais pas au
hockey
merci samir abbés leur vie non ça
m'enchante
elle n'a pas pu venir ça c'est mais moi
je viens d'abord comme sûr je garde tout
va bien tout ça c'est elle qui va venir
travail sera vous oui bien sûr on over
quand même
[Musique]
non petits soucis avec la vente ils
veulent pas nos cieux mais c'est pas un
petit souci va à oui oui c'est très très
grave
je ne sais pas d'où il vient cet argent
c'est ça pour l'aimer quand tu vas à la
banque demande devient le podium dont 6
et on doit bien des banlieues toi tu
gagnes en humour
je voulais savoir si tu pouvais
peut-être venir déjeuner avec moi ce
soir j'ai dit une connerie que ce qu'à
midi ces déjeuners
il était jeune et fraîche et la
nourriture on mange quoi
[Musique]
alors la cohabitation ça se passe bien
et juste attention à pas laisser traîner
nos affaires
[Musique]
annoncé out
c'est un signal je suis parti tout seul
soit 187 km nous sommes et comment tu
vas rentrer je sais pas mais c'est tard
s'appelle comment t'as vu déjà calé en
moi cette année et moi pas trois elle
est où la terre des ancêtres tu vivais
c'est pas grave on va trouver normal
qu'un avion demain soir mais d'abord on
va marcher mais non on s'est dit moi je
préfère dakar demain soir j'ai un avion
ça c'est lui qui nous a plantés pas bien
mais oui on les avait fait à manger ça
c'est pas moi les buts à 5 y en a pas
merde
la voiture est tombée en panne oui la
vieille voiture est tombée en panne
parce qu'elle était guérie usées ah oui
tu es vraiment naïf c'est là que tout
commence
pourquoi t'es jamais venu au sénégal
c'est pas ici toi comment ce soir ça se
voit tout de suite que le chemin de
hausse est continue à guider tepa merci
que la terre de tes ancêtres tu dois y
aller
pourrais tu as fais wayne toussaint
tchéquie pour un gamin comme toi
samedi face à ce qui est un blanc je
suis l'homme mois yahoo n'est pas blanc
tu es juste un bounty à on dit
à marie tu ne nous montrent rien c'est à
croire qu'il n'ya que du vide en toi
bachir de lille europe john hay adams
queen anne's a réussi à nous réserver
une place de 6e can find the right one
[Musique]
service de recouvrement de créances
prenez vos affaires personnelles qu'est
ce qui s'est passé je suis en faillite
je peux pas danser ici
j'aimerais savoir si je pourrais venir
m'entraîner
quand je bloque sur un truc je tente
autre chose sadi est ok un petit peu de
hip hop 4 5 6
c'est ça s'appelle un battle j'ai
assisté à la transformation jeté du
passé de danseuse médiocre et danseuses
formidable d'un prof particulier c'est
ça non
raconter à tes amis ce qui se passe non
j'ai rien dit
je peux savoir ce qui se passe
un petit conseil mon pote éloigne-toi
d'elle sinon toi aussi à capri braqueurs
ok allez c'est pas grave on recommence
non non
monsieur klein ou encore alors votre
pièce comédie et tragédie tragédie
comédie
le titre qui recule savinien cyrano un
poète avec un grand
ce qu'elle soit très bien il faut juste
rire les répétitions commencent demain
matin et la cathay pacific walker a
monté parti pour dix jours ça manque un
peu de cul marchera jamais
votre verve amusé à cet acteur ce n'est
pas tous les caractères du monde que
voulez-vous que j'y fasse que qui parle
du loup et bien mes amis ça sent le
succès je vous préviens cher myrmidon
qu'à la fin de l'envoi le jeu louche je
touche
nous allons modestement crayères
ensemble un chef-d'oeuvre
comme à chaque fois voici l'auteur est
de mon instant génie comme à chaque fois
en six mois que tout va bien se passer
tout va bien social passez moi
lequel après tout ce post je ne sais pas
et roxane qui fêtait je ne sais pas ils
respirent les gorillaz
je sentais qu'elle soit sans cette pièce
comme si j avais tout ce que je n'ai pas
le courage
l'humour l'héroïsme l'amour là moi
sur le véhicule et 1 minute
ça je n'ai jamais vu
[Applaudissements]